Washington Post now saying earlier
versions of the story and its headline
inaccurately characterized comments by
Senator cotton the term debunked and the
post-use of conspiracy theory have been
removed because then as now there is no
determination about the origin of the
virus Joe Concha joins us now good
morning Joe how are you doing
all right I was out for a couple of
companies guys you're going to see this
mark on my face here it was infinitely
bigger uh over the over the weekend but
I had a lesion on my face and it had to
be frozen off because at one point it
could have become cancerous so a little
PSA before we begin our segment uh go to
a dermatologist get your face and your
back and your body and your chest
checked out if they see anything that
looks a little weird it could be taken
care of quite easily if you let it sit
there for a while it could become
something a lot worse and a lot more
difficult to deal with so just so
everybody's at home like what's that
thing on Joe's face now we know what it
is and what maybe we could all do to
take care of things before they become
worse so there you go well we missed you
we're so glad you're back and I'm glad
you got everything checked out and it is
a good time to to get checked out by the
dermatologist by everyone you know let's
absolutely let's get into this segment
today's New York Post reads it had to be
woo so when you come off of what Brooke
just talked about in her piece you know
we spoke to Jonathan fegey about this in
the 4am my biggest issue with this is
why were people labeled racist
conspiracy theorists or both you know
why is it not okay in this day and age
to just ask the questions if you're
wrong you're wrong you correct it you
move on once more information comes out
so so what is it about this like why
they're being canceled they're being
censored they can't just ask questions
and be curious these days
and precisely it happened to our own Dr
Nicole Sapphire right as you as you just
played I mean the vitriol and the
backlash she got was was incredible and
you look back on all the coverage there
wasn't a hint of curiosity Ashley about
the lab League Theory when it was first
presented by Senator Tom Cotton it was
immediately dismissed as a crazy
conspiracy theory and any talk of even
entertaining this idea had to be shut
down right we had to believe the Chinese
communist government instead because
they're always on the up and up this is
what they do in North Korea and Jon
Stewart had the best perspective on this
before it was fashionable to do so and
this is what he told was shocked Stephen
Colbert all right oh my God there's been
an outbreak of chocolatey goodness near
Hershey Pennsylvania what do you think
happened like I don't know maybe a steam
shovel mated with a cocoa beam or maybe
it's the expletive Chocolate Factory
maybe that's it in other words if there
was a chocolate outbreak in Hershey
Pennsylvania it probably came from the
Chocolate Factory Factory if a virus
breaks out in Wuhan Pennsylvania in
Wuhan China and there's a lab there that
studies coronaviruses maybe there's a
good chance it came from there too and
Colbert of course dismissed Stewart at
the time so now the two questions are
will Dr Anthony fauci finally concede he
may have been wrong here and another
question will President Biden ever
confront Xi Jinping in terms of how this
was Unleashed on the world I have a
feeling no is the answer to both of
those questions Todd yeah I will see
your nose and I'll raise you two more
no's uh so I'm done giving predictions
here now we need another prediction from
you Lori Lightfoot lagging in the latest
polls one day out from Chicago's mayoral
election she is currently in third place
just 13 standing there she's behind a
guy with 32 and a guy with 18. so my
question for you Joe is what do you do
in this situation oh you uh play the
race card Lightfoot telling the New
Yorker I'm a black woman let's not
forget certain folks frankly don't
support Us in leadership roles seems
like a desperate Hail Mary to me Joe do
you think she's winning
and as you know from watching enough
football Todd Hail Marys are rarely
answered this is the result of crime
completely it's always been bad in
Chicago but now it's spilled over to the
areas that are supposed to be the good
parts of the city and everybody has had
enough of Lori Lightfoot and when you
play the race card from the bottom of
the deck which is which is what she's
doing that is literally what we're
seeing a Hail Mary here if in San
Francisco the district attorney could be
removed a deep blue City then in Chicago
a deep blue City can also remove their
ineffective mayor where crime has
completely gone out of control under her
watch and she seems to have no Solutions
around it this is what happens elections
have consequences Lori Lightfoot will be
gone when we're talking on Wednesday
guys
that's the second one today so we'll see
we'll find out in a couple days
we will indeed guys thank you so much
for having me and uh what I've known
about predictions though in politics
maybe maybe don't be so definitive I
think she will probably be gone how's
that well you know what happened when
you predicted the chiefs were going to
lose the Super Bowl
I'm sorry
no really we're really glad you're back
thanks Joe
excellent end zone dance there Ashley
thank you congrats from homes in the
Chiefs once again I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm aimsley Earhart
And subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis